San Salvador fue testigo de la marcha
negra así se denominó la manifestación
de 500 personas en la capital del país
Quienes se movilizaron en contra de la
aprobación de seis artículos de la ley
integral del sistema de pensiones
sindicalistas trabajadores y miembros de
organizaciones sociales se dirigieron a
la casa presidencial en oposición a la
reforma Qué es mentira que la pensión
mínima
estamos protestando porque esas son
pensiones miserables para nosotros
además de los trabajadores
organizaciones no gubernamentales
también expresaron su preocupación por
la política de gobierno de nayib bukele
como es el caso del instituto
centroamericano de estudios Fiscales
quien cuestionó los métodos del
ejecutivo y la sustentabilidad
financiera del cambio
para el Instituto las reformas
presentadas por el ejecutivo no dan una
respuesta integrada a los problemas
estructurales del sistema de pensiones
en términos de cobertura suficiencia
equidad y sostenibilidad
esta controvertida legislación forma
parte del paquete presentado por el
gobierno en septiembre de 2021 y que
otorga el manejo de recursos a las
administradoras de fondo de pensiones a
pesar de las solicitudes de
nacionalización de algunos sindicatos
según los datos de sefi 8 de cada 10
personas adultas mayores actualmente no
tienen acceso a una pensión y solo una
de cuatro tienen un trabajo remunerado
que ingresan en el sistema provisional
asuntos no tratados en la reforma